Here we're going to talk
about constructionism.
Constructionism is a learning theory and
probably the most influential
learning theory of the past century.
If you've taken a psychology class,
you're probably familiar with
constructivism, the brain child of
Jean Piaget, that describes how people
learn about the world around them.
Constructionism is a learning theory
from Seymour Papert, that takes those
ideas of constructivism and
applies them to how we should actually
develop curricula or develop activities
to best facilitate student learning.
Constructionism is really about putting
the learner in the center of learning
activity, and having them actually
construct an understanding
of whatever concept we're
trying to teach them.
It suggests that we can't just pour our
knowledge into a learner's head, but
really they have to build their
understanding of whatever we're
communicating to them.
Now constructionism is kind of
the umbrella over a lot of different
pedagogics that we'll
talk about in this class.
It's the umbrella over project based
learning, problem based learning,
learning by design,
learning by example, learning by doing.
All of these things put the student in
the center of the learning process and
have them construct their understanding
of a concept through some
authentic experience.
So constructionism is really
about facilitating that active
learning process, putting the learner in
the center and having them experience
the concept in an authentic way and
construct their understanding of it.